[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre magazine
de l'éducation comment se déroulent les
journées de vos enfants comment travail
des enseignants qui sont tous les
intervenants qui viennent enrichir les
programmes des élèves vous allez tout
savoir grâce à liberté égalité scolarité
et voici le sommaire
on vous emmène dans un atelier mécanique
dans l'oise ici on visse et en boulogne
pour restaurer une type de la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est l'épreuve du
chef-d'oeuvre pour les baccalauréats
professionnels
puis on enfile son uniforme et sa
casquette le temps d'une journée on part
en stage de cohésion du service national
universel
quand l'opéra s'invite dans une école en
réseau prioritaire c'est le défi des
concerts de poche une association qui
fait chanter carmen à des petits élèves
de cp
et enfin retour en archives sur le
baccalauréat alors que tous les lycéens
de france attendent leurs résultats on
vous propose de découvrir comment cette
épreuve mythique a évolué au cours des
décennies
[Musique]
pour obtenir son baccalauréat il faut
passer des épreuves écrites orales
réviser ses leçons d'histoire géographie
à prendre des formules scientifiques
mais pour certains il s'agit aussi de
présenter un chef-d'oeuvre cela concerne
tous les élèves en lycée professionnel
tout au long de l'année ils travaillent
seuls ou collectivement sur une oeuvre
qui leur permet d'exprimer leur talent
en lien avec leur formation alors ici
dans la section mécanique du lycée pro
paul langevin de beauvais les élèves ont
travaillé sur la restauration d'une jeep
de la seconde guerre mondiale ici c'est
un modem et on va voir tout de suite le
véritable véhicule sur lequel il
travaille actuellement un véritable
chef-d'oeuvre collectif est historique
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour qu'est ce que vous êtes
en train de faire là écoutez on en train
de remonter jeep willys de 1942 donc là
on est toute la partie châssis roux
moteur honda milieu dessus et là il est
en train de remonter toutes les pièces
qu'on nous a données donc là simon en
train de revoir tout ce qui est you de
frein maxence est en train de fixer le
boîtier de direction
vincent le pédalier et puis maxime qui
en dessous là il est aussi sur les
tuyaux de frein d'accord donc pâture
sert en fait pourquoi il sous le circuit
d'accord
je tends bout pour effectuer le freinage
ok ok to et aidons dans des cartons
c'est un vrai puzzle exactement
[Musique]
ça va voir une voiture aussi historique
n'annonce pas participé au débarquement
elle a participé au débarquement c'est
une vraie origine d'accord je vais aller
voir le propriétaire de la jeep
à quel moment vous êtes dit je vais
confier mes pièces détachées un lycée
professionnel pour qu'il remonte le
véhicule que j'ai acheté en pièces
détachées l'équipe pédagogique de
langevin est venu visiter notre
association notre club à satory un club
et de restaurateurs de véhicules
militaires hillion me racontent leur
histoire il cherchait un véhicule pour
un projet chef-d'oeuvre pour les classes
de première terminale et autres
je me suis dis bah j'ai ce qu'il vous
faut alors bien sûr quand ils ont vu
l'engin qui était en pièces détachées
ils ont peut être
mais ça s'est fait comme ça tout
simplement est ce que vous leur faites
totalement confiance oui je fais
confiance à l'équipe pédagogique
ça c'est clair ce sont des
professionnels de l'automobile plus que
moi et puis de la même manière mais je
fais confiance aux élèves et j'ai vu
qu'il y en avait quelques uns qui
étaient des vrais passionnés vraiment
war moi j'adore
[Musique]
comment tu sais côté gauche conserve
annoncèrent du côté droit donc là je
fais que leur choix là je sers si ça ne
vient pas dire c'est qu'on peut encore
serré donc voilà c'est bon en place et
donc la seconde ne faut pas forcément
parce que sinon on casse la vie ça
presse embêtant tu l'as pas c'est à toi
si tonton examen et explique moi un
petit peu comment ça s'est passé bah ça
s'est bien passé parce que justement moi
aussi j'aime beaucoup tous et tous ces
véhicules là donc moi ça m'a plu de le
faire ce dossier franchement ça m'a plu
de quand ils nous ont dit qu'on allait
restaurer ce que j'étais super content
pdc lis beaucoup et donc aussi bien la
partie orale que la partie écrite donc
du coup qu'est ce que tu as raconté un
pompier a raconté comment on avait fait
la rencontre du propriétaire pourquoi il
nous l'a prêté tout ça donc ce qui était
prévu a normalement ne partirai pas je
débarque avec mais avec le co vite tout
ça on a mis des problèmes qu est ce qui
fait qu'elle ne peut pas la faire ou les
poinçons bd même et bientôt j'espère de
cela c'est toute cette partie là c'est
ce que tu explications et à l'écrit donc
à l'écrit j'ai montré des photos de
l'avancée de la voiture d'ann à quesques
juste derrière tout ce qu'on a fait tout
ce qu'on a cherché aussi sur internet et
voilà j'ai tout lu tout vu qu'est ce que
tu as gardé de l'ange de cette épreuve
du chef-d'oeuvre je le garde parce que
moi voilà je me suis amusé avec mes
copains à faire ça voilà c'est un bon
truc contre moi franchement elle veut
garder toute ma vie et j'espère
une bonne expérience donc moi je le
garde toujours ses parents si je vais
pouvoir me vanter dire voilà j'ai
restauré cette voiture
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
installez-vous
[Musique]
très bien on va continuer pour faire le
lien entre votre chef-d'oeuvre et votre
voyage scolaire donc ils sont arrivés
débarquement alors
par quel avion bateau effectivement avec
l'idée que cette jeep en fait elle avait
la capacité d'être monté très rapidement
a le record du monde c'est sept minutes
pour remonter une jeep entièrement sept
minutes
ah bah oui pas pièce par pièce et bloc
par bloc évidemment un sujet ils ont pas
mis sept minutes à faire ce que vous
avez fait en trois ans non quand même
pas
donc des blocs qui s'emboîtent
standardisation et très fonctionnel si
je comprends bien vous les préparez
enfin vous essayer de lier chef-d'oeuvre
et voyages scolaires c'est ça tout à
fait dès le début on avait le projet de
remonter la jeep et de faire les
manifestations du débarquement avec la
jeep que nous avions resteraient
malheureusement ça n'a pas pu être
possible donc on n'ira pas avec notre
dip mais ils vont quand même aller sur
ces plages à une date symbolique puisque
on ira pour le 6 juin ça vous fait quoi
du coup d'aller sur les plages du
débarquement mécontents ouais ça n'aura
rien de plus ce qu'ils ont vécu ou là on
avait vécu là on va vie on va aller sur
le lieu où ça c'est pas si au lieu d'en
parler encore ouais vous en verrez des
photos des vidéos très sympa merci
beaucoup je vous laisse travailler merci
encore de nous avoir reçus au revoir
[Musique]
cette année quarante mille volontaires
de 15 à 17 ans se sont inscrits au
service national universel un dispositif
géré par l'éducation nationale pour
promouvoir la citoyenneté l'engagement
et l'insertion des jeunes première étape
le stage de cohésion 12 jours en
uniforme pour apprendre la vie en
collectivité s'initier aux sports de
combat et mieux comprendre les valeurs
de la république et ici à tour comme
dans tous les centres en france la
journée commence par la levée des
couleurs
ternes aux
prêts pour les couleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrêt
on a 90 est volontaire sur le centre
globalement tous envie d'être là et
envie d'être là pour faire quoi c'est
quoi le but du shc accroître la cohésion
et la résilience de la nation je n'avais
pas idée que vous qu on faisait ça on
qu'on demandait aux jeunes volontaires
de se mettre au garde à obourg au repos
il ya quand même des petites
ressemblance avec le service militaire
ou pas vraiment comment vous attendez un
petit peu là dessus alors dites moi
alors nous ne sommes pas sur un service
militaire
mais le garde à vous qu'est ce que c'est
c'est ni plus ni moins que le prenez
garde à votre position prenez garde à
votre maintien lors du lever des
couleurs donc c'est un respect des
couleurs si je vous dis que le s est nu
c'est un peu le le prolongement de
l'éducation civique à l'école ça vous
parle oui tout à fait tout à fait si ce
n'est que ici on est dans la nature
on y passe non seulement la journée mais
on y passe la nuit
on y vit on y mange on y nettoie à sa
chambre on y vit avec les autres à 24
heures sur 24 très bien bon allez on
vous suit bien sûr sur les plages 1
c'est ça alors nous allons sur la plage
on vient faire pour le combat les amener
au sol
[Musique]
l'abbé genou on prend un peu la pause et
on fouette
hop hop et là il oublie pas par sécurité
de mettre la main allez c'est parti
le pet cinq fois chacun
e 2 voilà très bien ensuite vous avez
vous approché encore plus ses pieds
voilà ici ce bras vous l'emmenez là bas
et ici technique
et ben merci merci à vous si ça c'est
pas de la cohésion
je ne sais pas ce que c'est que la
cohésion tally comment tenue uniforme
normal paulo paulo pas d'accord allez
bon courage de
porter un uniforme c'est bizarre moi ou
c'est
pour parler de sa rei on est tous
pareils et le truc classique mais tout
ça ne tient
aucune différence entre nous et si j'ai
bien compris la démarche il ya un stage
de cohésion c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de faire en train de vivre et
après 84 heures d'engagement
dans une mission d'intérêt général ce
que vous avez tout trouvé votre mission
d'intérêt général oui moi je vais
essayer d'aller à la spa
regarde là une vie et ensuite on va
trouver à proximité mais l'idée c'est de
rester près de chez soi oui voilà mais a
plein de composition du curseur où on
peut aller et en fait on a juste à
quitter sucre
[Musique]
m
alors nous sommes en tenue officielle et
ses menus et donc ce matin là on a un
certain nombre d'intervenants d'accord
ils vont tourner je me rappelle en
barrettes en tournant d'atelier en
atelier sur le thème de la santé
générale de la santé
le principe c'est quoi exactement une
chanson des
princes et
de brandir
tout n'est pas très bon on fait passer
le message que ba prévenir c'est mieux
que des rires c'est vrai qu'on met le
paquet aussi un petit peu plus sur la
santé mentale parce que voilà ça a été
compliqué le tout ce que la crise
sanitaire et puis voilà les jeunes
adultes c'est pas toujours facile donc
voilà si on essaie de les rassurer
[Musique]
bon alors on change complètement de
sujet on passe sur manque de france
d'accord un budget il faut toujours
qu'ils se soient ou positif ou équilibré
mais jamais négatif est ce que ce type
d'activité la apprendre à gérer son
budget vous trouvez c'est une bonne idée
ça nous prépare pour la vie d'adulte que
les plus autonomes après qu'un ferry
puis déjà conduit saab c'est bien on
commence à avoir des gardes lankarani
five on apprend déjà j'ai bien reçu au
quai
je peux rentrer
alors expliqué - peuvent vous êtes
organisé un petit un petit salon
c'était pas comme ça à la base si
sévère et nagy quand même d'accord soit
et donc là vous êtes combien exactement
dans la maisonnée de tous 12 hockey
anaky rond
pourquoi vous êtes inscrits ouassini moi
c'était du volontariat en fait j'avais
vu une vidéo c'était sur un petit jeu là
pourquoi qui parlait du et ses nus et en
fait j'ai trouvé ça trop cool jean-louis
ce qu'a raconté ça y est le parent qui
ont choisi ce qu'ils y aillent j'étais
partante mais et ça va je m'imaginais un
truc très strictes ça l'est pas tant que
ça oui vous n'avez pas vos téléphones là
c'est pas la panique non
ce soir fait deux jours qu'on soit sûr
de toujours
on a tendance à se cacher derrière le
téléphone quand on ne sait pas quand on
est timide et baala du coup ça nous
plaît on a
ce qu'il veut pas être tout seul battu
pas très bien très bien personne vaut
profiter de mon internet
synthèse ok c'est un test avec je vous
laisse tranquille bon elle tout à
l'heure à total on se retrouve tout à
l'heure d'hiver
cet après-midi le sujet c'est
développement durable il ya collecte des
déchets sur la loire tout ce qui
traînait par terre au
niveau vous regardez une droite à gauche
si vous avez des déchets vous les
ramasser et on nous faisait rien pour le
cei dont on prend un maximum entre 4
et 6 attends toi à choisir la position
ce que tu penses que c'est important que
ça fasse partie du sm cet éveil à
l'environnement c'est un acte citoyen
j'aimerais limites que ce soit un
réflexe pour eux de voir un déchet et
désire même si c'est pas à moi je le
prends et je le mets dans la plaine
et à la fin de chaque journée il ya un
conseil de maisonnée regardez à quoi ça
ressemble
qui veut commencer à prendre la parole
ce qui était bien c'est qu'on a
travaillé que la maisonnée une et on
n'avait pas encore parlé becali bas on
as tu rencontré des gens certaine si je
n'avais jamais parlé puis sont floutés
recours à la journée est intéressante
parce qu'au début on a fait un débat
tout ça et ce après midi on à jardiner
donc on a fait plusieurs choses
différentes dans la journée de la
compréhension est intéressant pardon je
me permets je peux qu'est ce que vous
faites de ces remontées une fois qu'elle
vous ont communiqué les choses positives
des choses négatives qu'est ce que vous
en faites bassin c'est un moment de
partage et en même temps on enfin oui on
en profite pour faire remonter les
soucis d'accord voilà
eh bien merci beaucoup merci pour tous
merci nous avoir accueillis je pense
qu'on a tous compris valérie on est
heureux de vous a reçu vous n'allez pas
repartir sur la casquette du service
national universel abba super voici pour
vous merci je la ramène à paris alors
très bien et bien merci encore au revoir
au revoir à bientôt
[Musique]
et maintenant on rejoint les concerts de
poche c'est une association qui fait
chanter des élèves tout au long de
l'année ils forment les enseignants et
surveille les coûts pour que tout ce
soit à l'unisson dans le plaisir du
chant ici à l'école alain 1,2 mo les
répétitions ont déjà commencé avec
peut-être la prochaine maria callas ou
le futur duce nos pavarotti suivez-moi
[Musique]
avec la garde montante
hockey
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
parle d'un fait doucement parce qu'ils
sont en pleine répétition échec et moi
un petit peu comment est née cette folle
idée des concerts de poche oui tout
avait en fait c'est gisèle magnan qui
est des pianistes concertistes ont
utilisé des concerts un peu partout en
france et dans le monde qui a eu
vraiment envie de partager sa passion
pour la musique classique le jazz opéra
auprès de tous et notamment là où la
musique est moins présente il ya un
informateur en l'occurrence ricine
formatrice qui vient en fait donné des
cours à l'enseignante son corps qu'elle
puisse elle même apprendre aux enfants
ces essais l'eau c'est un peu ça
principe j'ai effectivement aujourd'hui
astrid notre formative elle est
cohérente dans cette école auprès de
magali nantes on accompagne qu'elle va
superviser la séance et à la fin de la
séance celle des prix ensemble elles se
donne des objectifs pour la séance
d'après et l'objectif c'est qu'à l'issue
de la formation et l'enseignante soit
autonome et puissent gérer toute seule
sa séance
[Musique]
sur chaque partie vous êtes des
personnes des personnages différents on
va interpréter les personnages
différents le cas chaque fois qu'il
fallait pour travail la première partie
la partie house est petit comme
personnage avec l'atteinte d'objectifs
vous aider
des enfants des petits des enfants qui
jouent des soldats super
[Musique]
alors on va prendre la note avec antoine
c'était vraiment très bien tout ce dont
vous avez fait de fulton
[Musique]
ping pong c'est beaucoup à une claire tu
l'a senti là toi tout rond ce que
j'aimerais que le début d'année de jeudi
ils font ça tu l'a vraiment sur ce thème
pause cet échange il est vraiment
vraiment fait de gros progrès à tu et
juste s'il ya une chose améliorée pour
la fin de l'année s'il prend le temps de
donner la première note vous aviez déjà
des notions de musique classique
d'auchan alors pas du tout j'ai aucune
notion musicale mai depuis je suis
enseignant qui je pratique la chorale
avec toutes mes classes sans formation
d'accord avec ce que j'ai pu piocher à
droite à gauche mais c'est vrai que
cette année c'était un vrai plus pouvoir
participer comment comment on apprend le
chant le chant classique carmen à
quelqu'un qui n'en a qui n'a aucune
notion de musique à la base on essaie
d'être de la manade jeudi qu'ils soient
de la manière la plus simple qui soit
disant la nature on vous en fait ça va
bien se passer il est vrai que la manne
pour les petits bouts de chou de 2 cp
c'est très exigeant et c'est un niveau
supérieur à ce qu'ils disent qu'ils
pourraient chanter leurs déguisements
vers les yeux comme ça et maintenant où
sont ils donc voilà c'est qu'on a on a
réussi notre table
[Musique]
tous les lycéens de france viennent de
passer leur baccalauréat alors en
attendant les résultats je vous propose
un petit retour en arrière pour
comprendre comment cette épreuve
mythique aîné et comment elle a traversé
les époques c'est notre capsule old
school préparé par le réseau canopée
enlevez les maths garder la philo
évaluer toute l'année ou lors d'un
examen final et pour en faire quoi
puisque tout le monde là chaque année
rien ne vaut le baccalauréat pour
enflammer les débats
créé en 1808 par napoléon 1er le
baccalauréat entend redresser un système
éducatif tenus par les religieux et
malmené par la révolution il marque
aussi la volonté de constituer une
nouvelle élite non pas par la naissance
mais par le mérite l'intention est belle
mais le bac restera longtemps réservée à
une infime minorité de la population et
qui plus est uniquement aux garçons en
1861 julie victoire daubié est la
première femme française à obtenir le
baccalauréat mais elle fait office
d'exception et les lycées attendront le
milieu des années 1920 pour ouvrir leurs
portes aux jeunes filles
malgré la gratuité des lycées publics et
l'allongement de la durée de la
scolarité seule une minorité persévère
au delà du certificat d'études
l'après-guerre change la donne avec
l'explosion des effectifs dans les
établissements de 32 mille bacheliers en
1960 on passe à deux cent trente sept
mille en 1970 soit un taux de réussite
de plus de 60% à côté du bac général
l'éducation nationale instaure en 1968
le bac technologique puis en 1985 le bac
professionnel
l'objectif faire réussir 80 % d'une
classe d'âge à l'horizon de l'an 2000
jean pierre chevènement 85 créé le
baccalauréat professionnel c'est une
audace tout à fait remarquable puisque
au fond on donne la dignité du
baccalauréat un des parcours de
formation qui est jusque là les têtes
des formations courtes destiné à entrer
rapidement dans la vie active
le taux de réussite progresse doucement
et en 2021 la france frôle les 94 % en
moyenne tous baccalauréat confondues le
bac il faut l'avoir enfin quoi que tu
veux faire au moins tu auras toujours
tombe à quoi présenter et c'est vraiment
la base passant le bac là on n'a rien
surtout dans la filière générale en fait
nous on est obligé de continuer après
le bac est devenu un symbole et chaque
enfant se doit de l'obtenir pour accéder
au statut d'adulte là
vous dès aujourd'hui à non je vais
changer prendre la vie certes j'en ai
car le bac n'est pas une fin en soi il
est considéré comme le premier grade de
l'enseignement supérieur or on constate
un taux d'échec important durant les
premières années post bac pour y
remédier la réforme de 2021 inaugure de
nouvelles modalités pour la voie
générale épreuves nationales allégée en
première et terminale et contrôle
continu pour un nombre renforcé de
discipline
[Musique]
et voilà c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui
mais on se retrouve très vite pour un
prochain numéro
[Musique]